hey drew the point of the share the mic
now campaign is to amplify the voice and
the work of black women
and ignite change through sisterhood i
know you're a lover of design
which is why i'm really excited to
introduce you to this dynamic duo today
they're tavia forbes and monet masters
they are the owners of the interior
design studio
forbes and masters as principal interior
designers
their work can be seen in homes and
commercial spaces
around the country they're so gifted in
their way to compose design
they're just my favorite and actually
they redesigned my office
so meet tavia and monet please welcome
back to the show my good friend lovey
hi lovey how are you today good good
making it you always are and what
brilliant women are you bringing to the
show today
i have tavia forbes and monet masters
for you they
are incredible they're my favorite
interior designers
and their eye for style is fire well
let's meet them tavia forbes and monet
masters
hello ladies
hey lovey hey y'all um
i was researching your work and i loved
it so much and
i would love lovey to uh
pose some questions to you guys so we
can just get to know you better but
i'm so happy to be with you guys take it
away
yeah renee i have a question for you so
like tell us about this dynamic
partnership
you both have at forbes masters how did
this come to life what is this
this magic y'all create together the
iconic
story um so it's a very funny story i
was
actually taking on my very first
commercial project
and it was exciting because i was in
knee deep struggle but it was also
overwhelming because i had never done
a commercial project and um had more
experience in residential so long story
short
we got to a point where the client was
like
how do we move forward what are the next
steps i didn't know how to gather the
contractors
i didn't know how to do anything and so
in in a
attempt to help me they contacted tavia
forbes to
um to consult on the project and to help
me and i did not allow it i didn't like
the idea of it
and um they end up firing me and hiring
tavia to complete the job
and because i was just so focused on
bettering myself and growing within the
industry
i ended up calling her that night and um
told her that i wanted to keep in
contact with her
and um that was the start of a beautiful
relationship and then we got thrown into
our very first project and we've been
busy ever since
okay i didn't know where that story was
going
and i love it so
much i just think for people hearing
your story
and how you started and how you game
together and that your partnership makes
you so much stronger
it's just really inspiring thank you
so i went to ask davia how would you
describe your signature style
i i would say our style is bold eclectic
but still tailored
uh we don't really fall into a genre but
we want to do
every genre with like a punch of
something
extravagant yes i'm here for that and it
shows up in your design
and you guys i have an odd question
which
is how has the pandemic sort of affected
your practice well
everyone's looking to get something done
nowadays
um from home offices
to just meditation spaces places that
they feel like their home can be a
retreat
and um to that point like zoom is huge
so
you know everyone's looking for a zoom
background now right right
i think in general a lot of people are
just looking for a beautiful designed
space and do you guys have any quick
ways
um or advice on how to enhance your
space
now that we are all in our spaces
oh yes absolutely uh paint
it's the easiest cheapest thing you can
do um but consider
painting your walls like a bold punchy
color and like
also go ahead and paint the trim and the
baseboards while you're at it
um you if you put a piece of r in
a really nice sleek frame against that
really bold color it's gonna look very
sophisticated very chic
and another great thing uh is uh zoom
calls right zooms or
zoom calls are very important right now
so your backdrop is
even more important um putting up a pill
and stick wallpaper
one of one of which you could select
from the forbes masters collection
or even just a console table with some
beautiful oversized accessories maybe a
mirror piece of art above it
would give you the the perfect backdrop
to
your uh your zoom calls well i
absolutely love this and i
cannot love your wallpapers more and if
you go to the drewberrymoreshow.com
we're going to have a feature
on tavia and monet because you're so
talented and your work is so beautiful
it's really an honor
to have met you through the great lovey
you know this this just makes me happy
because i just want good people to know
good people
and this is what this is like i hope
people understand that the gift
of forbes masters team listen you need
it in your life
i couldn't agree more i really look to
you levy
as a leader um in this space
and i'm just so honored to always be
being
taught and uh shown you know these
incredible
people uh because of you you're just
making everyone's life so much
bigger and brighter you expand all of
our horizons by bringing us all together
and lifting everyone up
my pleasure i'm gonna keep doing it so
yeah let's keep doing it i'm so lucky i
get to do this with you really and truly
thank you lovey thank you tavia thank
you monet
[Music]